[Music]
can't believe that we're here together I
just want to make sure I'm not dreaming
the cast is here we're celebrating the
show tonight but also kind of the
closing of a chapter how does it feel to
be here it feels great it feels it's
really exciting that we get to celebrate
as you said and then look forward to the
potential legacy that we've been talking
about for a long time there's so much
positivity surrounded with this show and
what the fans have been doing and what
they've been trying to make it into and
you know moving forward if this is the
end then at least we have a positive
happy smiley legacy to leave behind us
can you tease for us about the finale to
ours right yeah everyone guys and now is
that I'm almost 23 I'm realizing looking
at at 50,000 feet what a huge
influential transitional chunk of my
life that was and the fact that I was
able to be surrounded by so many
wonderful utterly wonderful artists for
beautiful people I couldn't have asked
for anything I learned so much about
myself but about my work and about
everything I grew a lot what message do
you have for the fans who have stuck by
you guys during the series just thank
you thank you for everything we've had
the best time making the show and is
that a family
want any regard at that so we hope we do
be proud web 12 episodes in there you
know we filmed the last two and news was
a great experience and you know we
really strong yeah we're close we're
looking forward to the strong finishing
I mean it's you know it's not going to
wind along with like people get tired of
it it's gonna hit a good end people are
gonna be happy I'm really looking
forward to it be happy heartbroken how
they react I mean all of them all of you
happy above all else yeah we just want
to make everyone super happy and just go
with everything that people want with
the characters so we're kind of
exploring all the storylines that that
needs to be done and we're doing it in a
family of two hours and it's gonna be
amazing
what else can you tease for us any words
you used to describe it
heartbreaking and joyful and exciting it
has to be crazy right it's kind of a
chapter closing for you how does that
feel yeah it's been such a wonderful
ride I came in the last season and to
meet everybody here we've been it's been
a little bit of a family so it's going
to be sad to say goodbye but it was a
wonderful
[Music]